in this video I want to talk a little
bit about transcription initiation in
prokaryotes we talked a little bit about
the transcription machinery in the
previous video of prokaryotes and
eukaryotes so we're going to elaborate
on the prokaryotes here in through this
diagram so if we imagine that we have
here we have double-stranded DNA let's
think that this strand up here that has
the 3 prime end on the left side and the
5 5 on the right side let's imagine this
to be the template strand now this up
here is going to be the hollow enzyme
and if you recall the hollow enzyme is
made up of the core enzyme which if you
recall has 2 alpha subunits and Omega
subunit a beta subunit and a beta prime
subunit and the blue portion here is the
Sigma subunit that's specific to
particular genes now if you recall the
Sigma subunits purpose is to help the
core enzyme bind the promoter region of
the DNA so if we imagine this region
here to be the promoter the Sigma
subunit is going to help the core enzyme
bind when it binds it forms this thing
called the closed complex and the reason
it's called the closed complex is
because these two strands of DNA are
wound around each other I have not been
separated so what needs to happen now is
the helix needs to be unwound and forms
the open complex so once we have this
open complex form the RNA polymerase the
holoenzyme can begin to make RNA so it
adds a few nucleotides and this here in
blue is of course the RNA that we're
making so it begins to move forward and
forward in this case is heading this way
because it's reading this template
strand 3 to 5 prime so it's going to add
bases that are complementary 5 prime to
3 prime so after a select few amount
of a select few nucleotides are added
the Sigma subunit leaves so this is the
Sigma subunit here so after a few
nucleotides and T stands for nucleotides
are added the Sigma subunit dissociates
it falls off because it did stop the
Sigma subunit was solely supposed to
help the core enzyme bind and once it
gets going once the quran's i'm gets
going the Sigma subunit is no longer
necessary so the core enzyme continues
on and polymerizes RNA so what end here
is the free end of the RNA that end is
the 5 prime end because the RNA
polymerase is going is making things 5
prime to 3 prime so I mean the first
thing that it made was at the 5 prime
end and it keeps adding things to the 3
prime end so then what then what happens
well then it's elongation elongation is
just the the idea that this RNA
polymerase is going to continue act
adding nucleotides it's going to keep
adding them it's going to keep adding
nucleotides
when I say keeps going I'm talking about
the core enzyme it keeps going until a
termination site is reached and that's
about it for
and prokaryotes initiation of
transcription in prokaryotes I hope that
video was helpful one last thing I am a
tutor if you live in Southern California
feel free to contact me via email at
move University at gmail.com and see the
description below for more details thank
you for watching